so the question is can congress impeach  president trump  after he's already left office it's a  really interesting question because the  text of the impeachment clause of the  constitution  seems to imply that the person still  holds an office after all  one of the main results of an  impeachment can be although it's not  necessarily  removal from office remember the  impeachment is the indictment and then  the senate would try the actual  impeachment charges and potentially  remove you from office then again  another one of the punishments is not  being able to hold office again so  that might be a reason to try them  afterwards but in terms of historical  precedent in 1876  congress actually did impeach the  secretary of war who had already  resigned so there is some past precedent  anyway stay tuned for more election  coverage and i'll see you  in court